this is because contentious but like if
you know if I reckon there needs to be
like a brand change but I felt like if I
concentrate on this maybe I can come up
with something maybe I can explain the
maths as a joke maybe I can put the
things together feel like I know
something and it's not really being said
I was Adam Spencer he was doing stuff
and other people in the past had sort of
done some things and it was really even
though there were people like Anna's
fence it there it was such a young and
almost like spanner
virgin land uncharted yeah it's totally
uncharted yeah yeah yeah and so and so
yeah so one of the first successful
things I did because I kind of I kind of
had the performance stuff worked out
before the jokes but I think my first
successful one was the sodoku because I
because I was doing because I done
sodoku because people kept asking me are
you good at seduction and it's like yes
and it's like oh how come it's like if I
didn't know how to do this there'd be a
problem you know what I mean it's I've
got to have at least some respect yeah
you got to pull that kind of thing off
oh yeah it's kind of like it's such a
you know it's like imagining like Herod
guitars like I do you know do you know
how to place their way to heaven or
Green Day it's like yes it's like if I
didn't know how to do it it'd be shame
on you shame on me yeah yeah you're not
worthy of the name of yep yes okay so
that's what I did I was looking at
Sudokus and I realize that the numbers
which they use are just it's actually
just nine different symbols I realized
this very early on and then I kind of
thought you know people actually look at
numbers and just get scared and so I
thought I'm gonna try and make this
accessible to like the most the
antithesis of someone of the nerd and in
my mind it was like it's a bogan and the
baigan it and you can get away with
saying that in Australia because there's
an affectionate tutor you know
everyone's got like I've got a bug
inside me you know what I mean so so
then I ended up taking exchanging the
numbers for football teams and I made
this joke and it was like it was really
exciting because it was still maths and
it was like I was explaining maths but I
was explaining I was like I was always
actually talking about how people feel
towards when I was kind of flipping it
around so there's this misconception
there that to be maths it has to be
numbers yeah as soon as people see
numbers that's kind of that up well
that's close to me that's not I think
that I'm interested in that's right yeah
yeah yeah well people just turn off I
mean like if I if I had I mean this is
because contentious but like if you know
if I reckon there needs to be like a
brand change I think maths I mean it
the idea of maths I think a way of
better communicating it is
problem-solving abstract problems hoping
to be more precise but I think
problem-solving at least kind of gets to
what is so amazing about mathematics and
what mathematics is given to me all the
maths that I've solved all the work I've
done is that it actually has given me
the ability to think abstractly and that
has been that's actually the skill that
it's really developed yeah more than
just about numbers but different clan do
yeah yeah well because like like you
know numbers are they're just a
construction of maths at this time soon
I mean it's it's like maths is more than
than what the way we write it there's a
language that's used to talk about it
yeah there is yeah yeah and then there's
the thing itself just yeah well that's
the crazy thing is that when you study
maths for a really long time you kind of
like or for example like say say like
you're looking at whole numbers positive
whole numbers right and you look at them
and you kind of realize oh yes so whole
numbers so there's a number like 12 and
I can break it up I can say that's 4
times 3 or you know I can talk about 2
times 6 and so there's these different
ways to talk about the way these numbers
are
produced but then you move on to 13 and
13 only one times 13 or 13 times one I
mean you can go into fractions and but
if you stick the whole numbers right
into this whole number world they may in
the whole number world you have these
weird numbers 13 and in there's 17 and
there's three and there's five and so
you might go okay so a number which can
only be expressed as itself times one
that's really interesting so I'm going
to call these numbers box okay and and
and the thing is is that I've discovered
this and I've put a name to it to kind
of give it a handle right and so I can
describe it so I can keep it so you can
move yet so you can basically have a way
of taking it and moving it around and so
then you kind of play around with these
numbers and you realize that twelve even
though it's some even though it's two
times six and three times four
if you go two times two times three
that's as far down as it goes but then
you go oh yeah but then there's 2 times
2 times 3 times 1 and there's 2 times 2
times 3 times 1 times 1 and there's 2
times 2 times 3 times 1 times 1 times 1
times 1 and so basically you can keep
multiplying 1 and then it you still get
all this repetition then you realize if
I exclude 1 then there's a way of
expressing these whole numbers uniquely
the other way - yeah sit down any
further
yeah or if you do dig down you'll always
end up at the same yeah so there's like
these patterns and so what you say is
you say if I look at Bob's but I exclude
one I'm gonna call them primes and so
you've just discovered this thing called
primes and it has a definition because
of the structures that you're
discovering and so what's called unique
prime factorization because then you
start using big words because like you
go I'm gonna show you how smart I am but
now you can t start using words that
sound big and kind of scare people the
idea is is that is that whole numbers
can be expressed in these atoms and then
these and then you look at prime numbers
and you discover
all these new things and you think but
the point is is that these things are
discovered it doesn't matter how I write
it down if I write it in binary I can
write it as numbers I can even write it
as Roman numerals which isn't very
efficient but that's not the point the
point is that these these things are
discovered and the problem I think is
that so many people get taught this and
the way we get toward is here's the
facts learn them and they sort of they
come to you as just a mutable body
that's already pre established it's
always been true and everyone's all it's
true that's right so what's great in
doing Matt's comedy and what might I
think my main kind of modus operandi is
is the fact that I'm really trying to
get people to see Matt's differently and
so like the sodoku the most important
thing a serious thing for me is that
they're seeing that this sodoku thing is
a structure that is different to to the
like this perception of as just numbers
and even my Pythagoras's theorem when I
do my proof of Pythagoras theorem
there's so many ways I could prove it
and there's so many ways can prove it
without using algebra or numbers so I do
a pictorial way which is fine as unless
you're dyslexic there was problems but
people who is not kind of better see
that so that is immediate to you yes it
is so there's this there's another way
there's another way I have to explore
for people who suffer that but but yeah
so for people like myself well you know
fortunate enough to have these visual
things pop what's really great is that
you can actually cut you can actually
cut the the two squares in a certain way
and it's like a jigsaw mmm but the way I
show how to do it is this beautiful way
where you you infer so you have two
areas that are exactly the same you cut
them up differently and then you take
away equal areas and so it's really kind
of a logic exercise if the logic
exercises but what's what's really
important is is that all of maths is in
that proof because you're taking the
visual so these things that you can
prove visually like physically like I
can put one on top of the other I can
see they're the same
you're using those things to prove
something that you can't see visually so
you can't and that automatically go okay
well that area plus that equals that my
and then when you follow the logical
argument you go oh yeah it's inevitable
to get that result out yeah but that's C
in mathematics that's what we that's
what you do is that you take these facts
and then you go somewhere new and you
and you really want to kind of go
through this trapdoor of of discovering
something that you couldn't have found
out unless you had that knowledge it's
about broadening out and this is this is
this is why I'm excited by mouths and
why people you know if it's like you
know what I mean it's like it's always
some reason you come up with like and
it's like no seriously am I seriously am
interested in this because I love
solving problems and I love that's the
these structures that you discover I
mean I really love maths and I'm so
lucky that there's so much ignorance out
there that's why I get to try and
explain it to people